hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar mechanisms of myeloid amino
suppression functional characterization
of the tumor micro-environment
using single and multiplex IHC presented
by Chris Grange IHC specialist cell
signaling technology I'm Alexis Krause
of laberd's and I'll be our moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by laborat and brought to you
by cell signaling technology to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license good question
box and click send well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the
top-right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left ear screen this presentation is
educational and the software's
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker mr. Chris Grange
chris has close to 10 years of
experience working with a variety of
Amida has took chemical techniques and
technologies his main focus over this
time has been development and validation
of IHC grade antibodies in a number of
research areas for a complete biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
Chris you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction Alexis
and thank you everyone for joining us
today so I'm going to talk about
mechanisms of myeloid immunosuppression
and how we can functionally characterize
the tumor microenvironment
using single and multiplex ihd
so just as an agenda for today I'll
discuss some of the I'll discuss why the
tumor microenvironment is so important
in some of the key questions surrounding
it I'll briefly talk about some key
markers in Abuna oncology and in IHC
space then I'll talk about two of the
most important functional markers of the
myeloid suppressive tumor
microenvironment we'll spend most of the
time today discussing the construction
of a fluorescent multiplex I see panel
and then I'll get into a bit about
optimization of the dual flex
chromogenic ethic and then we'll
conclude and there'll be time for some
questions at the end so as most of us
know new cancer therapies are being
approved faster than ever and while many
are focused on immunotherapy and
antibody based therapeutics they all
require a deeper understanding of the
tumor microenvironment it has become
clear that even small molecule
inhibitors can be affected by conditions
within the TMA and that understanding
these conditions is key to protecting
response rates and efficacy of all
cancer treatments the current
understanding of the interaction between
the patient's immune system and tumor
has led many companies to develop
biomarker driven diagnostic tests
alongside lead drug candidates many of
these diagnostic tests today are based
in single pucks chromogenic
IC IC remains the critical application
for understanding the tumor
microenvironment as it allows
researchers to detect biomarker
expression while maintaining the spatial
context within tissues
this is crucial for looking at variables
such as - localization of certain
biomarkers along with the proximity of
different cell types to one another not
only can we simply phenotype immune
cells within the tumor microenvironment
by IHC but we can also get an
understanding of what compartment they
are residing
like to bring up the example of PDL one
in this context as it is an
immunosuppressant marker that can be
expressed at many different cell types a
number of assays for example Western
blot could tell you that PDL one was
present in these three lung tumors on
the right however once you homogenized
the tissue you lose the context of that
expression we would not know that PDL
one expression in the lung carcinoma at
the top was mostly confined to tumor
cells or that the tumor in the bottom
left expressed PDL one almost
exclusively on myeloid cells finally it
would be impossible to know that PDL one
expression in the lung on the bottom
right was only on T cells within the
stroma
you
in order to perform even a simple single
pledge crow mechanic ihe s a highly
validated anybody's are required I want
to quickly show case a number of immuno
on ecology focused targets for which TST
has highly validated IC grade antibodies
start with some Co inhibitory molecules
that are expressed on both tumor cells
and on immune cells here we have a
selection of Co inhibitory molecules
such as T 1 Tim 3 and lag 3 which we
know are expressed on T cells among
other cell types and also markets such
as b7 H 3 and D 7 h 4 which can be
expressed primarily on tumor cells
moving on we have post stimulatory
molecules in our catalog as well
molecules such as IKOS and gator and for
one BB which are currently in the clinic
and expressed mainly on t-cells and also
the pan t-cell marker cd3 along with
ox40 and is right and ox40
l
further we have some targets which can
help researchers understand the
crosstalk between T and D cells we have
the classic
t-regulatory marker Fox p3 along with a
marker cytotoxic T cells cd8 and some
other markers such as CD 19 cd4 T and
cd40 ligand as well and finally we have
markers of myeloid cells here on this
slide as you can see we have CD 68 which
is commonly used as the pan macrophage
marker CD 163 which is a marker of
immunosuppressive macrophages CD 11 C
which is a marker of dendritic cells
along with some other one of myeloid
markers such as CD 206 and CD 14 as well
so
number of anybody's directed against
these key myeloid cells targets many
questions remain with regard to their
functional significance in the tumor
microenvironment
questions such as the m1 versus m2
paradigm
cd68 as I mentioned it's been used as a
pan macrophage marker but is it truly a
marker of all macrophages and is it
marking only macrophages what is the
functional significance of the
immunosuppressant Marcus CD 163 and then
these other markers of myeloid cells
what are their functional significance
and what type of cells are they labeling
so using ihd to phenotype the myeloid
compartment of the tumor
microenvironment clearly has many
advantages and it led to a number of
breakthroughs however this only gives a
snapshot at a fixed point during tumor
progression or treatment the question is
is this a fair way to characterize the
tumor given the plasticity of myeloid
cells mainly macrophages
and then finally how can we determine
the functional contribution of
macrophages in the middle of this
spectrum so you can see here on the
right I'm just showing this sort of m1
like macrophages on the left course the
empty macrophages on the right and using
IHC to determine the functional
significance of these macrophages that
sits somewhere in the middle of this
spectrum has been difficult for
researchers and continues to be but one
way we can try to understand that is to
look at functional markers of myeloid
immunosuppression such as IO and Arjun
A's
so to start with I doe can suppress the
mutagenicity in the tumor
microenvironment in a number of
different ways they can disrupt calcium
signaling and tryptophan metabolism it
can activate regulatory T cells leading
to immuno suppression or it can
interfere with T cell metabolism by
inhibiting food co2 uptake
immune cells are the main target of
tryptophan depletion as tumor cells have
a number of ways to withstand these
effects for example tumor cells can
remodel their cellular metabolism by up
regulating several genes which allow
improved glutamine and tryptophan import
into the cell and on the right here I'm
just showing a few images of I dose
staining on the top you can see an
ovarian carcinoma while on the bottom we
have a colon carcinoma and you can see I
know expression in the ovarian carcinoma
is mostly in the tumor cells while in
the colon carcinoma it's mostly on
immune cells within the stroma and the
lamina propria
moving on to RJ's one it can be
expressed by tumor in myeloid cells and
can also lead to immunosuppressive
conditions within the tumor
microenvironment tumor expression of
Archana T's one can deprive immune cells
of arginine leading to T cell
dysfunction Arjun a is also inhibits
tumor recital nitric oxide production by
inflammatory macrophages expression of
Arjun is by immune cells within the tme
can have similar immunosuppressive
functions and here on the right we have
some single bloodstains of a human lung
carcinoma actually these are both human
lung carcinoma is on the top and the
bottom and here we see our Janae's
mostly expressed by immune cells and
we're not seeing any expression on tumor
cells
so now I want to get into the
optimization of a multiplex ICSA which
is fluorescent based
so there are a number of ways we can
attempt to do multiplexing in IFC I'll
go through three of those on this slide
so you can see on the left the first way
would be to use a directly conjugated
primary antibody this has some benefits
in that you can use the same anybody's
raised in the same species to multiplex
but it also has some drawbacks
especially in formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissues
FFP tissue generally generate a high
amount of autofluorescence and using
this directly conjugated primary
antibody method does not provide much
amplification at all so in most cases in
empathy tissues you will not you will
not get signals sufficient enough to
overcome the autofluorescence
of the tissue another method that people
sometimes use would be to use directly
conjugated secondary antibodies here we
would deposit our primary antibody onto
the tissue and then use use
species-specific secondary antibodies
conjugated to different fluorophores
in this case we can only use anybody's
of anybody's raised in different species
so for instance we could use most
anybody's a most anybody a rabid anybody
and there may be another most anybody of
a different class again we run into the
same issues where we're getting in this
case a bit more amplification of signal
but oftentimes it's not enough to
overcome the autofluorescence within the
tissue so this brings us to the
technique that we'll be using today
which is pyramid based amplification
system and it's currently the best
option for multiplexing and FFP tissues
so to remind signal amplification or tsa
requires the binding of the primary
antibody to the target antigen followed
by an incubation with an HR p conjugated
species specific secondary Tara mine
molecules which are conjugated to four
fours become activated in the presence
of horseradish peroxidase and are
deposited via covalent bond onto the
tissue this covalent binding is the
crucial step that allows from
multiplexing
up to in our case today six different
antibodies so a bit more about the tsa
si in particular as I mentioned on the
previous slide you have your primary
antibody bound to your epitope in your
tissue you come in with a HRP labeled
secondary antibody followed by
incubation with the pyramide conjugated
fluorophores which are activated in the
presence of the HRP and covalently
deposited onto your tissue at this point
you're going to microwave your slides or
perform some type of heating step which
will remove the primary and secondary
antibodies but leave the covalently
bound tear amide and floor for attach to
the tissue at this point we can come in
with a different primary anybody again
with the HRT labeled secondary and then
a tear of my molecule conjugated to a
different floor form and we can continue
to run these steps the primary secondary
four four followed by microwaving and
then come in again with another round of
staining and what this does it allows us
to multiplex not only using a number of
different targets up to six as we're
doing today but also allows us to use
antibodies raised in the same species
because between each round of staining
we're stripping the antibody and then we
can come in within anybody of the same
species
so for our immunosuppressive multiplex
IHC panel today I'll talk a little bit
about why we selected the targets that
we did so the first target would be CD
68 which we're using as a macrophage
marker in this case then we have Ida and
Arjun is one which I discussed earlier
which can provide insight into the
mechanisms of immunosuppression in the
micro environment we've also included
PDL 1 and PDL 2 which as most people
know regulate T cell activation and
immune responses and can be expressed on
multiple cell types within the T MA
and then we'll use Pan keratin as a
tumor cell marker as well
so in constructing our multiplex IHC
panel we need to begin with highly
validated IC grade antibodies and I'll
talk a little bit about how we validate
these antibodies here at CSD in the
community of chemistry application
so what we do is we generally start with
a number of clones against the same
target and we'll test those on
paraffin-embedded cell pellets the most
common model we'll use an is an
endogenous model so one cell line that
endogenous endogenous ly expresses our
protein of interest and one that does
not and this not only allows us to do an
initial
initial test to determine if our anybody
can bind to the target of interest but
it also allows us to determine an
optimal solution with which to move
forward on tissue because we want to get
to the point where the negative cell
line shows no signal and where we still
have signal in the positive so on and
this usually helps us to determine that
that optimal delusion to move forward
with on tissue knowing that solution
doesn't guarantee that it will be
correct so the next step would be to do
a small titration on a known positive
tissue sometimes we'll actually is a
negative tissue as well so we'll have
another level of validation in there
from there we'll move on to tissue
microarray testing and we make all of
our TMA's in-house and they usually
include 60 to 70 unique tumors and those
will come from eight to nine different
tumor types so every anybody or every
human reactive antibody that we release
and approved for IHC from cells and no
technology has been tested on you know
up to or at least I should say at least
50 to 70 different tissues prior to
adding the IC application to the CST
website and then we'll finish up with
either peptide blocking to just do a
final level of validation or for our
fossil specific antibodies will do a
lambda phosphatase treatment to prove
that they're in fact binding to the
phosphorylated protein
so once we have our stock of highly
validated I see great anybody's we can
move on to the primary anybody titration
using the pyramide reagent so what I'm
showing here is our PDL 1 e 1 l 3 n
chrome being titrated using pyramind
conjugated to the side I've died on
positive and negative endogenous so on
so you'll notice a few things here you
notice that clearly the mean
fluorescence intensity is highest when
we use more primary anybody but you'll
also notice that the signal-to-noise
ratio between the positive and negative
cell line can bounce around a little bit
so we want to consider both of these
things both the mean fluorescence
intensity or positive signal and also
the signal-to-noise in determining which
dilution we want to use in our panel
it's important to note that this these
two factors aren't the only ones to keep
in mind but I think it's something to
look at initially and to kind of
determine a smaller range of dilution
rather than having to do this this huge
titration when you're optimizing your
full panel
the next step would be to look at each
to look at each target using each floor
for so we're here we're looking at which
floor fours will pair best with each
primary antibody and you can see again
with PDL one on the same cell color
model side three is giving us the best
signal to noise and also the best mean
fluorescence intensity per cell but you
can see that fitzy alexa fluor 594 or
sigh five would also be pretty decent
options
the next step would be to optimize the
order of staining and what we're doing
here is we're using each antibody in the
panel and we're going through the
heating steps so here I'm showing on the
left
if this anybody was used first we would
do only the antigen retrieval we stain
the anybody and then we look at the
slide if we're using it say in the
fourth position
we go through every heating step then
apply the antibody and then look at the
slide to determine the strength of
signal in the mean fluorescence
intensity and also the signal to noise
and this will allow us to determine if
the epitopes that we're trying to detect
may be affected by multiple rounds of
heating as you can see with TD l1
this is kind of a unique target in that
with multiple rounds of heating we get
greater and greater signal which
suggests that PDL one can withstand not
only withstand multiple rounds of
heating but also the signal gets
stronger and stronger and we can infer
that what's happening is that the the
epitope is continuing to get a little
bit more unmasked with each heating step
so once you have your panel to a point
you consider optimized it's important to
compare the staining in the full panel
to both the single plex to both a single
flex stain slide
so I'm sorry let me start over this is
an important slide and I want to make
sure that we cover so once you have your
panel to a point you've considered
optimize it's important to compare the
staining in the full panel to a single
plug slide stained optimally and by that
I mean with only one heating step which
is the antigen or triple step and if I
heated the same number of times as the
marker and the panel so for example if
we were looking at PDL one in the fifth
position here we would heat the slide
that many times then apply only the PDL
one anybody so looking at these two
control sides compared to the multiplex
slide allows us to validate a few
different variables first we can see if
we are losing signal in the multiplex
slide due to steric hindrance we found
here at CST in developing the maybe 12
to 15 different panels that we have that
the binding is something anybody can be
affected by the order of staining if
that were the case we would see
diminished signal in the multiplex slide
compared to both single plug stains if
you run into that phenomenon we found
that just switching up the order of the
staining can help it requires a bit more
optimization but in the end you get a
more robust panel that that gives you a
truer expression a truer look at
biomarker expression
in another case if the epitope are
sensitive to multiple rounds of heating
we would seek administration when both
the multiplex lies in the heated slide
and could rule out any steric hindrance
issues
I'll also note that I'm showing in this
light our newest most reactive
immunology panel and you can see the
markers in white in that multiplex paint
section and I'll provide a link at the
end of the webinar for more information
about this panel
so switching back to our
immunosuppressive panel the next step
would be staining of control and tumor
tissues with your fully optimized panel
so you can see here this is our
immunosuppressive panel stained on a
human tonsil which is a control tissue
we use for many of our immuno oncology
targets and you can see each of the
markers is represented within this
tonsil and and the standing is looking
strong and specific with each marker
here we're looking at a tumor tissue
this is a lung carcinoma and again you
can see all of our markers are present
we're not really seeing any bleed
through or overlap in these signals and
everything seems to be looking good
to highlight this panel and the optimize
conditions that we ended up with I'll
just leave this slide up for a minute
you can see that PDL 2 is paired with
Alexa fluor 594 Ida with 555 Archana is
one with 6e PDL one with sy v DD 68 with
size five point five and finally
cytokeratin with Alexa for 350 and this
information again I'll provide a link at
the end of the webinar that leads to an
application note that will give you a
little bit more detail in in regards to
the protocol
so just some key considerations to keep
in mind when optimizing a teammate but
to revive a s--t multiplex ihe panel
so all optimization stuffs must be taken
out of the hole so this goes back to
where I mentioned that looking at just
the signal-to-noise or the mean
fluorescence intensity per cell is not
enough you need to consider all the
variables together and how they will
mesh with one another one thing I didn't
mention yet is the antibody stripping
step these steps each has to be QC for
each marker so for instance when we were
optimizing this panel we found that I
believe it was IO you know when we when
we did the general stripping step which
for us is a heating ten minutes in the
microwave and citrate buffer Idol wasn't
completely stripped so what we did was
we we changed the buffer to EDTA and we
found that the stripping step was was
complete and that a hundred percent of
the signal was gone after stripping so
it's important to test the stripping
efficacy with each marker as I mentioned
steric hindrance can be an issue in the
order of staining matters and the key
point is that the controls are crucial
it's important to compare to not only
chroma genetic staining in a single plex
setting but also the single plex
optimized fluorescent staining and the
heated single clutch Fersen staining as
I mentioned previously so I just want to
show a couple images this is the same
image of the tonsil but you can see on
the left I've broken out into the single
channels all of the markers that are
present
you
here we have an ovarian carcinoma and
again you'll notice we're seeing a bit
more idle expression as compared to our
Janae's in this tumor and here's that
lung carcinoma again and in this case
it's kind of reversed you'll see a
higher expression of RJ's one which is
in green versus Ida which is in yellow
and so once the panel is optimized the
acquisition of images and image analysis
is the next step to be performed this is
a bit outside of the scope of this
webinar but I just wanted to mention
that here at CST we use the metro system
from PerkinElmer and we use the in-form
tissue finder for our image analysis and
again I'll provide a link at the end of
the webinar that will lead you to some
posters that we presented and some of
the image analysis data that we've
generated
so now I want to switch gears and talk
about dual Plex chromogenic fa
development
course there are
benefits and limitations to duplex
painting in the chromogenic setting so
as far as benefits go its more common
than fluorescent labeling it it doesn't
require additional instrumentation such
as a fluorescent microscope or image
analysis software chroma Genex painting
is widely accepted by pathologists once
the size of stains they're stable
basically forever whereas when you're
standing with a term I based system the
slides are good for maybe up to a month
but after that the signal fades
dramatically and there's more solutions
available for automation what I mean by
that is we can in most cases transfer a
chroma Jana cafe to a automated Center
such as the Leica bond or the Ventana
platform much easier than it would be to
transfer a manual TSA based multiplex
epic but of course these limitations as
well usually we're limited limited to
about three chromosomes per panel just
because of the way the colors interact
with one another same species
multiplexing can be more challenging
because the chromosomes may not be as
heat stable as Jeremias and in most
cases we cannot use targets expressed in
the same compartment meaning we want we
wouldn't want to look at something like
cd3 and cd8 which are both expressed on
the membrane of a subset of T cells
because the chromosomes can block each
other out and it's difficult to
determine where true co-localization is
occurring
you
so some a say some sorry some variables
to consider in the duplex chromatid a
cafe we want to think about the host
species so are we using too many bodies
from the same species if so we'll have
to perform a stripping step in between
each protocol obviously we need to
optimize the primary antibody solution
and the antigen retrieval step as I
mentioned the stripping step needs to be
optimized as well the pairing of the
chromosomes with each of your primary
antibodies and the order of staining
meaning which chromatin is deposited
first versus which is posited second so
for this example I'll be showing our cd8
and Fox p3 most reactive clones and
these are both rabbit monoclonal
antibodies so we'll have to perform the
stripping step in between each protocol
so as I mentioned the first step is the
initial titration of each primary
anybody using each of the different
chromatids so here we're looking at our
Fox t3 product and you can see the image
in the top right is on dab optimal which
was previously optimized at 1 to 400
this is on a mouse clean and you can see
I've done a titration here from 1 to 100
to 1 to 800 of our primary anybody using
the alkaline phosphatase read chromatin
and you can see that right around 1 to
200 matches matches up pretty good
without a gap optimal solution which was
1 to 400 and here is the cd8 titration
in the red chromatin again we had a dab
optimized protocol which was good at 1
to 400 and this time in small intestine
and you can see that at 1 to 200 the
signal intensity and specificity with
the alkaline phosphatase red chromatin
matches nicely with what we see in the
jab optimal protocol
you
so after the single collects
optimization with both antibodies and
chromatins
we need to test the efficacy of our
stripping stone so I want to describe
the process that was used to determine
if are anybody stripping stuff led to
complete removal of the first primary
anybody so I ran the dual Plex protocol
for each of these conditions first I ran
the dab protocol but did not include the
dab chromatin I only apply the primary
antibody then I applied the stripping
step in this case citrate buffer heated
to 100 degrees C for 10 minutes I then
ran the alkaline phosphatase protocol
with no primary antibody
so
if the stripping step was 100% effective
then we should see no signal once the
assay is complete as the primary
antibody was only applied prior to the
stripping step as you can see in these
images there's still some red signal
with both Fox p3 on the top and cd8 on
the bottom interestingly
when the alkaline phosphotase protocol
is run first followed by Deb Fox p3 is
stripped more efficiently and cd8 less
if we ran just the dual plug that day
without emitting chromatin or the second
primary antibody it would be impossible
to know if the stripping was sufficient
so basically what I'm showing here is in
the first images on the left you can
still see red signal with Fox p3 and
with cd8 showing that our stripping was
incomplete when I switched up the order
and ran the alkaline phosphatase first
Fox p3 was actually stripped much more
efficiently and cd8 was stripped less
efficiently as you can see in the images
in the middle and then when I run just
just the dual process a without emitting
yves's chromatin or primary antibody we
can see nice staining but we wouldn't
know basically if the anybody was
completely stripped because the dab
signal would block out any red signal
that might remain MV crops reacting with
our first primary anywhere so since this
dripping step was not sufficient and did
not remove 100% of our first primary
antibody I increase the intensity so
what I did was I switched you EDTA
buffer for 20 minutes and this seemed to
do a much better job you can see with
Fox p3 on the top left stripping was
much better but still not complete and
with cd8 it was essentially 100 percent
strips and when we ran the alkaline
phosphatase protocol first as you can
see on the right and the damn protocol
second we shot we saw a complete
stripping with both Fox p3 and with cd8
you
the next step would be to optimize the
order so what I did was I ran the images
on the top show the alkaline phosphatase
protocol with Fox p3 run first owned by
the dab protocol with cd8 run second and
this is on a mouse small intestine on
the left and a spleen on the right and
then on the bottom you can see the
opposite so this is where I ran the dab
protocol a CDA first followed by the
alkaline phosphatase protocol with Fox
p3 second and you can see that when
we're running the dab first in that
alkaline phosphatase a second on the
bottom we get much stronger signal
certainly with with our cd8 clone but it
also appears that the Fox p3 signal is a
bit stronger as well so
in the end we determined that this was
the optimal order to complete sustaining
and to move forward with our optimized
asset
and so here I'm just showing you that
optimize that day so we use the dab
first with our cd8 clone followed by the
alkaline phosphatase read protocol with
our Fox p3 foam the initial antigen
retrieval step was EDTA for 20 minutes
at 100 degrees C and the stripping step
between protocols was again EDTA for 20
minutes at 100 degrees C as well so it
was kind of nice that we were able to
use our antigen retrieval step in
between protocols as the stripping step
as well and I'll just note that this
staining was performed on the Waco bond
Rx and so of course the citrate buffer
is the er1 buffer and the EDTA buffer
just the er-2 buffer
I'll also note that the the application
note that I showed when I first started
this section was of staining of cd8 and
PDL one and that describes manual duplex
ICSA and that is available on the CFT
website and I'll provide a link to that
shortly but the key point is that it's
not necessarily be sa type whether it's
manual or automated I think what we're
trying to to get across here is just
that the process in the thought process
and the steps to take in optimizing an
assay so it's more the the thinking
about how to go about optimization
rather than the specific steps and you
know how many washes between steps and
things like that any questions like that
you can always get in touch with us here
at CSD for the specifics
so just to conclude as we've discussed
infiltrating myeloid cells constitute a
significant component of the suppressive
tumor microenvironment our Jenna is an
idle monoclonal antibodies provide
insight into the mechanisms of
immunosuppression within the tumor
microenvironment highly validated ITC
grade antibodies are the building blocks
for every multiplex essay format and
finally optimization of fluorescent and
multi mo genetic multiplex panels
requires rigorous validation and robust
controls and so I hope I've gotten that
across to you today and I just want to
finish with a few resources that we have
at TSD so I've got links here for cell
signaling technical support with we're a
great resource here our technical
support wise you know if you send us an
email if you call us up you know just
going to talk to someone in customer
service who's reading to remain Yule
you're going to be able to talk to the
scientists who optimize these IEC essays
who developed these antibodies so we
really have a wealth of knowledge to
offer anything getting to the specifics
of not only the assay that I discussed
today but also troubleshooting of any
issues you've had and that goes for all
of our applications not just ihe not
just I see things like I have flow and
Western blot as well the next link will
bring you to some of the multiplex I see
posters and application notes that I
discussed earlier we have posters that
have been presented at a number of
different conferences this past year at
ACR we presented the poster detailing
the most reactive immune markers that I
discussed earlier
and then the final link here is to the
dual staining is the application note
that I showed an image of but failed to
mention specifically at the beginning of
the module staining section as I said
just a minute ago of that application
note details the development of an assay
of deviate and PDL one these are our
human reactive antibodies for those
targets in the manual setting but the
the the way to go about the assay is
kind of the most important thing in that
application note and again any specifics
you need about that assay you can just
follow the link to the IC technical
support and I'm going to leave it there
thank you everyone for joining in today
and I'll open it up to any questions you
may have thank you very much
thank you Chris for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left your screen
well as there as many of your questions
as we have time for let's let's get
started with our with our first question
um do you have any Mouse antibodies or
establish panels for Mouse tissue
yes that's a good question so we do
actually have a number of most reactive
anybodies so we generally will develop
anybody's raised in rabbit for use in
most tissues and we have a number of
those a lot of new ones that are focused
on immuno oncology targets in the mouse
and actually we recently presented as I
mentioned I think we recently presented
a poster at ACR about our newest
multiplex IHC panel which is focused on
most reactive products and that panel
contained markers for CD 3 epsilon P d1
cd8 PDL 1f 480 which is a pan macrophage
marker in mice and then pan keratin as a
tumor marker and that panel is available
on the CSP website it's under the poster
section and anyone interested who is not
able to locate that poster you can email
into technical support and I'll be happy
to provide that link for you
you
now Chris our next our next question is
where does the steric hindrance come
from the antibody or the terror map
reaction
this is a good question it's still a bit
unclear it's something that I think
people are beginning to realize is a
variable that has to be considered in
this type of multiplex essay I my
thought is that the steric hindrance is
coming from the pyramid itself being
deposited onto the proteins and so I
think that you can run into issues here
where you have things that are expressed
on on smaller cell types such as t-cells
and different markers that are expressed
in high concentration on the membrane
such as CD 3 and CD 8 and I think that
the term ID being deposited onto the the
proteins themselves can block the
binding of an antibody coming in you
know after the first one I believe that
the antibodies themselves are quite
small and and wouldn't be an issue
steric hindrance wise now like I said
it's still unclear you know exactly what
what the issue might be but my guess
would be that it's the termite reaction
causing it and we've messed around with
a few different conditions such as as I
mentioned switching up the order of
staining but another thing you could
attempt if you're having issues with
with a panel of your own is that you
could um you could use less pyramide so
that you know in theory would would help
with any steric hindrance that you
encounter
Chris I work in a preclinical setting
with a lot of mouse models can you
describe how to get around Mouse on
Mouse cross-reactivity issues
sure so as I mentioned with our most
reactive panel
most of our our primary antibodies are
raised in rabbit and so when you're
using rabbit antibodies in most tissues
you won't see any Mouse on most
reactivity now I know a lot of other
companies are raising their anybodies in
mice and that's going to lead to issues
with your mouse secondary reacting with
IgG within the mouse tissue but when
you're using rabbit anybodies you won't
run into any most of most reactivity and
you know this this is really helpful in
the the multiplex setting because you
know as as I mentioned with the term ID
based assay we can use anybody's raised
in the same species so being able to use
a number of different rabbit antibodies
within most tissues is is helpful in
this situation
now Chris how do you pass the antibody
stripping
so
tripping in the pyramide based assay
what we do is we'll stain the tissue or
will will stain the tissue with our you
know anybody of choice then we'll use
the pyramid conjugated for for that we
anticipate using in the panel then what
we'll do is we'll do a complete
stripping step we'll come back in with
dill youant only so no secondary
antibody
second primary anybody and then we'll
stain the tissue with a different floor
for
and then what we'll do is we'll image
and see what what colors are present so
let's say we had a first primary which
was cd8 stained with a sickly and then
we stripped and then we came in with the
SCI five let's say conjugated tear amide
if the stripping was complete that sy5
wouldn't be able to bind so under the
microscope we would see only the fitzy
yellow signal and no red Syfy signal if
the stripping was incomplete then you
would see some of that red Syfy's signal
where the cd8 anybody is because it
hasn't fully been stripped so that's
usually what we'll do we'll stain with
the primary antibody one color tira
might do a stripping step then a
second-tier amide and then we'll image
and if we see any color from that second
floor for T remind conjugate will know
that the stripping step wasn't
sufficient and we have to either change
the stripping buffer or increase the
heating time
now how do you deal with
autofluorescence well here at CSC we're
using the PerkinElmer system so we have
the Metra microscope in the in-form
software and so with with that scope and
software combination we're able to do
multi spectral imaging so multi spectral
imaging allows us to subtract any of
that autofluorescence before we actually
image the 404s and the antibodies within
our panel so that makes it really easy
to deal with auto fluorescence because
you can just subtract it out before the
imaging and get a nice clean image now
if you don't have
if you don't have a multispectral system
you're probably going to be limited to
three or four colors but that's okay
I've worked with that as well doing a
four color assay without multispectral
imaging and I found that the the
pyramide really amplifies the signal so
much that you can get a nice signal
without seeing any autofluorescence so
basically the term ID allows you to work
with very small exposure times which
kind of eliminates any autofluorescence
within the tissue
now our next our next question is what
are the advantages of the tire made
system compared to the side off systems
Hyperion from fluid I'm
yeah that's another good question the
Hyperion system from fluid I'm certainly
has its advantages and that you can do
up to I think something like forty
different antibodies in a panel which is
great I think you know there's still
some questions about how to analyze all
that data and what type of things you
want to look at with with up to forty
different antibodies but that system is
very expensive and you need to buy a
whole new instrument with the tyranide
based assay it's you know a lot more
cost effective and a lot easier to
implement in one's laboratory so I think
that while with the Hyperion system you
can use you know up to 40 anybody's and
on one tissue section it's not going to
be cost-effective for for every lab and
now I think with the pyramid based
system and with multispectral imaging
you can get up get up to about nine
different antibodies plus daffy so
that's a 10 color assay which which I
think just came out so you know it's
certainly is not able to handle the
number of different targets in one panel
but it is a lot more cost-effective and
I'll also mention that here at CSD we
don't have the high PRM system so we
have not tested are anybody's in-house
but we have heard from a number of
customers that are anybody's work really
well with a Hyperion system and that our
recommended manual IP solutions usually
transfer over pretty well to the
delusions that people are using in the
Hyperion panel so it's important to note
that you know if anyone listening either
has the Hyperion system or is thinking
about it CSC anybody's are a good choice
for that panel construction as well
and Chris it looks like
time for one more question are there
particular markers you would recommend
to better differentiate Pro from anti
inflamatory my load cells
yes so I discussed some of them in the
presentation today we talked about using
our jenay's one of course and I do is
functional markers as more phenotypic
markers some suggestions I have for the
anti-inflammatory M - like macrophages
one would be CD 206 of which we have in
anybody for obviously the classic m2
marker CD 163 CD 204 is another option
and then T G R sorry T P G m2 is
something people have been using
recently m1 markers are a little harder
to come by but some possibilities that
people might want to think about would
be i know c XE l 10 and SOC s1 as
possibilities and then another option
would be to use a pan macrophage markers
such as CD 68 in a multiplex fa so if
you use CD 68 and CD 163 what you can do
is you can take your CD 68 CD 163 dual
positive cells and subtract those from
your total population of CD 8 or cd68
positive cells and the number you're
left with there will give you your will
give you a pretty good estimate of the
m1 macrophages within your tissue thank
you Chris
do you have any final comments for our
audience
I think that
sums it up I'd just like to thank
everyone for listening in today and
again if you have any follow-up
questions please feel free to write in
to our technical support or call in all
that information is in the link that I
had on my last slide there and is
available on the CSC website and if you
just mentioned that you watch the
webinar you can talk to me directly you
know if you have any any specific
questions and thanks again
thank you again Chris for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank laberd's and
our sponsor cell signaling technology
for other writing today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast will be viewable on demand
through April of 2019 laborat alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thanks again for
joining us until next time goodbye